oh come on blacks and gardenia Danny
Zuko I love that so much welcome back
with our special guest coach guarantee
you know we were actually on set for
that in the grease portion no way we
were there what was what the whole
grease I'm her guardian course came up
with the whole idea the carnival and
then the last you know people holding
everything together and murdering just
representing the streets really strong
oh yeah you know I have to call you out
a little bit uh uh it's been five years
since we've gotten an Ashanti album so
when we get new music very very soon I
have a project coming out November 15th
that's gonna be crazy I have a single
out now you look pretty little thing
maybe you know folks have been asking so
you've got your answer you are a singer
you're also an actress and we have
actually got way back Wednesday one of
our favorite is John Tucker Must Die
surprise we were on that set - what am I
looking forward to about turning to look
at you know I guess getting a little bit
smarter making a little bit more money
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we saw that little bit there but you've
got a lifetime Christmas movie coming
out and I love this a called a Christmas
winter song yeah why are other people
gonna love this they're gonna love it
because the message is amazing it's not
just for Christmas I think it speaks
volumes and it'll resonate with people
that just go through things in life a
stranger could change your life and the
other is in Ashanti Christmas class okay
so you know there's a holiday in between
that Halloween yeah it's coming up yes
and you know you provide this and for
the best oh I got painted for like an
hour in that blue paint and it was
everywhere but it was worth it cuz she
was cute Smurfette excute did you hear
what he's gonna be this year I don't
know I have to top that one yeah it's
hard to top that cuz some pepper Smurf
is pretty lady
[Music]